alors qui veut jouer avec moi parmi vous
n'ont pas tous joué avec
comment j'ai choisir mon anar voilà bien
fait rejoignez là c'est moi la vie de
millions sympa non plus ne puissiez vous
faire un boulot de cartes jeux mais ou
rester à odom et andrew m aussi via la
toile a proposé de venir ici mais au
train de l'est via les gaillards de gens
le verront et mejia du border d'accord
mais on est plutôt mal faire là à tours
chaussé fiche alors ça gèle car très
souvent d'accord
donc vous voyez mon jeu de kart wii on
voit bien est ce qu on voit très très
bien ce qu'on va bien voilà je me
regarde je vais vous demander c'est joli
scoop à la vous voyez mon jeu de cartes
voyez bien oui je vais vous demander de
choisir une carte une carte au hasard
donc levé à mon avis parce que la table
est très haute
alors vous la regardez la regarde
oui je veux montrer aux caméras ou pas
vous pouvez la montre et les paquets les
nancéens les yeux à elle montré à la
caméra
dites-moi quand vous l'avez caché
d'accord qu'elle change la carte black
acheté mon fils qu'il a ce soir au
sérieux les cachets des canaris va et là
vous allez vous attendre à quelque chose
de magique quelque chose vous allez en
garder le souvenir toute votre vie
là je suis contraint de parole 20h02
votre esprit je vais d'ailleurs
ce que ça allait j'ai deviné votre carte
ah bon est ce que ce ne serait pas mieux
elle m'a frappé c'est quoi attendez je
vais approcher le mois prochain ses
lourdeurs du mec dans la rue mais il
faut la trouver ou à l'est mais où est
elle à l essai moi réfléchir avant de te
concentrer vers là je pense que c'est un
pari vallée de tavannes et reif voulait
cacher ou alain bernard sur tous les
sites a révélé voulait pas d'un regarder
mais j'aimerais vous faire peur c'est
que j'avais passé partition mais pouvoir
toi valait 1
mais c'est pas toujours c'est ça c'était
un fleuve je vis dans la vérité oui
alors on parce que tout ce qui se passe
là oui je l'avais prédit il ya au moins
deux jours deux jours elle pense à moi
tous les jours
regardez tout soutenons ce coup ça beau
ouais alors dans la salle g de bernard
menez sur l'instinct g de bernard
montiel 20 ans avec les amis je vous
invite à me retrouver ce vendredi là
notre ami maxime kelly pour la magie
selon gainey pourquoi
un truc vous allez je sais que tout
l'effort par les superbes 20h45 sur
c'est évidemment je ferai
au delà
les titres